is my name is aziza
i'm 32 and the hazara from ghazni
province
in kabul i worked as a tailor for an
american company
and then at the afghan defense ministry
but i had to leave
afghanistan i received
threatening calls and we were followed
even in the car
it was dangerous one of our staff passes
was blown up by a suicide bomber
my work was in the shash dark area of
kabul where the afghan intel office and
the us embassy were also located
i was traumatized when i saw the bodies
of the journalists killed in the attack
there aren't jobs or a good working
environment for most women in
afghanistan
i worked six years for the government
but it was hard for me to continue
in my work environment it was mostly men
people would talk about us the taliban
would also follow our staff
car or bus from the ministry so i left
recently about 25 girls were taken by
the taliban from the malistan district
of kazna province
and they were forced into marriage
i arrived in iran on a visa and then we
were smuggled into turkey
the journey was very dangerous and
difficult i was thinking at one point i
might die
but god helped me from iran to turkey we
paid
one thousand dollars each
i want peace and prosperity for my
country we're tired of wars
but that's all i've seen since i was a
child and i don't expect peace in
afghanistan anytime soon
i want to move to a safer place where we
can live in peace
it will be better for us